[Music]
so my name is JD I'm a senior product
manager in Google and with me is John
banning whose staff software engineer
and the technical lead for the
stackdriver query notation which were
very excited to introduce to you today
so we're gonna be talking about how to
incrementally build powerful queries
with the stackdriver query notation and
also how that gives you more flexibility
and power to increase the observability
of your applications and your
infrastructure whatever you use in in
Google Cloud and beyond but before we
get going I'd love to know a little bit
more about everybody here in the
audience so let's see some hands so here
is a developer all right what about an
operator or sre oh wow and both truly
DevOps we're doing everything yes a few
okay cool
anybody was a language geek Wow whew
awesome okay so hopefully we'll have
several things for each and one of you
but this is an intermediate level talk
we're gonna go into the needed retails
of query language that John simply
designed and worked with the team but as
I said we're hopefully going to show you
through demos and other things how we
get there so here's the plan we'll start
with a brief overview of observability
within stackdriver and particularly with
the query notation and introduce you to
query notation itself then we'll jump
straight into details from the beginning
I'm gonna see a lot of shorter demos and
showing how you can actually use this
language to create this very robust
powerful query so John will spend a few
minutes talking about how a basic query
is formed and then it's going to build
up on on that to create more queries and
then we'll get in even to some demos of
advanced queries then to come back to
the end recap and then give you some
call to action so you can actually get
access to query notation use it and of
course please give us feedback so let's
jump right in
so of course in the end we do have time
for questions we're going to live a few
minutes so I'm sure there's microphones
up here in the front which you can use
and
if we run out of time we of course going
to be also outside for you can come and
talk to us as well
so let's go write it into observability
so know whether you're a developer or an
operator as a reor you're doing both or
you're just doing analyses and so on
there's always that time when we all
wish we had just a little more
observability now maybe because you're
dealing with an incident in your
application and then your users are not
able to access your their cards and
their check out services or maybe
because you're doing proactive
monitoring and you're really trying to
do analysis on some you know specific
state of your application or
infrastructure or maybe because you want
to control a little bit of time and you
want to do demand forecasting you want
to look at how your retail application
is doing now that the man is getting
compared to last season of Black Friday
for instance in those cases you really
want to be able to go and inspect your
systems your applications in detail now
many of our server ability tools allow
you to do this in some ways very much in
the same way the stack driver does and
we're gonna offer you another more
powerful and flexible means to do this
so this is precisely the the whole idea
of being able to increase and get
observer ability for your cloud
applications is what stackdriver is
meant to do stack driver is a product
speed that offers a comprehensive set of
tools that together provide very rich
observability of your cloud environment
your cloud services your application and
so forth and so the idea that we're
trying to do in many of these services
and today we're gonna focus primarily on
the monitoring side we're gonna focus on
metrics and time series but the idea
here is that we want to take the toil of
doing ops management away from you as
much as possible those things that
really are hard to do or easily automate
a bowl and so forth we want to help you
take advantage of those so that you can
focus on what matters most which is your
business and your application and so to
that end we've been done enormous
machinery it's a set of systems that we
use internally at Google to also you
know how we monitor and get
observability for many of our of our own
products and so this systems bring
together a lot of different things
building metrics
I'm excuse me those three metrics and
logs as well as snapshots and traces and
we put all of those together they're
coming from cloud services they're
coming from our open source components
they're coming from cloud native
infrastructure even from other cloud
providers and we aggregate put those
together to help create and infer
relationships between resources to
understand and evaluate alerting
policies to alert you when a symptom of
perhaps the prediction of a failure may
come in and we give you powerful
visualization tools to do all of this so
that always with the intent of making
ops easy for you and increase that
observer ability so again if we focus on
the monitoring piece if you focus on
metrics and time series stack driver
monitoring of course allows you to do
this today you can inspect on demand in
stock driver monitoring using the
metrics exploring anybody here has use
of metric Explorer before a few of you
several of you great so for instance you
can look at the CPU request utilization
metric for those kubernetes containing
resources you can filter them by the
namespace that is let's say the default
namespace that has my application at
this moment and I can group them by
container name and by a location I can
literally do that with a metric and get
that on-demand type of visibility but
what if I want to do something different
what if I you know this may not be
enough and we know that you sometimes
you want to slice and dice your your
time series data and your metrics in a
way that is just convenient to you and
maybe you want to do composite metrics
maybe you want to do arbitrary math
functions you want to control time and
so forth so this is exactly what we're
doing today by introducing the stack
driver query notation stack private
query notation is a flexible and
comprehensive language that allows you
to do precisely that it allows you to
build powerful query metrics so you can
inspect on demand so that you can
analyze the state of your application
and infrastructure and so that you can
build robust dashboards so you can do
practice monitoring or also so you can
do alerting and then in general increase
the overall observer ability of your
cloud workloads now the stack driver
query notation is built on consider on a
consistent data model so it provides a
very solid foundation for all your query
builder
it is also based on a you know popular
pipeline idiom so it's easier to
incrementally build and debug those
queries that you have and it also offers
powerful operators for you so to do
precisely sort of things that I
mentioned composted queries
crates of composing functions arbitrary
math you know ratios time shifting and
so on which John is precisely going to
show us in in a few minutes so just to
get a sense of how this work let's do
you know this is a metrics Explorer and
we have already here a standard query
setup the one that we just mentioned in
the previous slide and what you can do
is you can click on query editor and
that should give you directly now the
equivalent of that essentially query
that you have now in query notation so
notice what do you have here it's
already group by window by mean and I
have another group by a container name
location and so on and I immediately get
the same time series that I would get
otherwise
now now how if this was all too fast
don't worry because this is exactly what
we're gonna be doing next Johnson's
gonna take us into the details of how to
start from a query like this and build
up on that in and show us several
advanced queries as well to really get
you into how you can increase their
ability of your apps so I'm gonna hand
it off to John who can start on some of
this journey all right I think we go
back to the slides now and here we go
we're gonna go through the query
notation in seven steps I'm not gonna
read these to you because we're gonna
start right in so basic query the the
most basic query every query in the
query notation starts with a fetch
operation the fetch operation we see one
here starts with the name of the
operation fetch and one argument which
is the name of a table when it evaluates
it's going to find that table in the
database and return it or produce it as
its output now you might be saying wait
a minute we have metrics we have time
series what's this table thing and
what's the table name so let's look at
that for a minute
out in the cloud we've got resources
that we want to keep an eye on here's a
kubernetes node and every kind of
resource has associated with it a yes a
monitored resource type in this case KS
node and the router resource type gives
us a way to name that resource and it
does so by giving us a set of labels and
every resource of that kind will have a
value for each of those labels the
project ID that owns the resource the
location where the resource resides is
being monitored from and the cluster
name a node name that we're given when
that kubernetes node was created and
they monitor resource type and the value
of those labels uniquely identified
every kubernetes node in the system now
now we're going to have a number of
metrics on each one of these nodes that
we're going to be monitoring and each
metric has a metric type here is a
metric type for allocatable utilization
on a node the fraction of memory we
could allocate that we're actually using
and the metric type gives the type of
value that the metric is producing in
this case double gauge gauge means that
it's a state of the system that we can
observe and that will sample to gather
data from being the amount of memory in
use at that time the other kind of
stream that we see typically as a as a
delta stream where each point is the sum
of some value like the number of queries
I've received or the number of CPU
seconds I've used over some specific
time period now the other thing that
might come with a metric type are some
labels this one comes with one label
called a memory memory type which can be
either a victim or non evict able so
there are two kinds of memory and we'll
basically have two instances of this
metric with different values for that
label to track the utilization of both
of those kinds of memory now these two
things together uniquely identify a
stream of data that we might be
interested in collecting and
we put them together in what's called a
time series identifier the name of that
time series identifier includes both the
resource name and the metric name has
all of the labels from both the resource
and the metric and this uniquely
identifies a stream of data that's
coming in from the cloud to stackdriver
to be recorded now that we have a name
for a time series we can start
collecting a time stories so a time
series has an identify that uniquely
identifies it and a history so we get
the history and consists of values that
we've observed the metric to have and
the time stamp when the observation was
made now obviously we have a lot of
nodes out in the cloud and they have a
lot of metrics and so we're going to
have a lot of these time series and you
might think of this slide as being
reproduced once for each resource and
metric type and they'll have different
labels but the time series same time
series identifier uniquely identifying
the time series and a history associated
with it now in order to make these time
series accessible to queries we gather
them together in a time series table
this is a relational straightforward
relational table it has columns one
column for each of the time series
identifier labels a timestamp column
oops sorry
I went way too far all right a timestamp
column and a value column so every row
in this table represents one observation
and that observations time is here in
value there and the time series it's
part of is identified by these columns
so you can think of this as containing
all of the time series that involve
acade kubernetes node and this
particular this particular metric and so
that's what the and the name of this
table is given by the
the the met the resource name and the
metric name and so that is what the
fetch operation names and the kind of
table that it's going to return all
right now let's start building queries
from that base we build queries with a
pipe operator that's the method by which
parts of queries are composed here a
pipe operator that connects different
operations here we have the fetch
operation we saw before connected by the
pipe operator to a filter operation that
we've added and the way this works is
the fetch operation produces a table
it's piped by the by the pipe operator
to be the input to the filter operation
which transforms that table in some way
and produces it produces it as output
which is then the output of this query
so we can order see this in this diagram
there's the fetch operation it's
producing a table that's input to the
filter operation which transforms it in
some way and produces another table as
output well what is the fetch operation
filter operation doing pretty
straightforward it's got one argument
which is a general expresses a boolean
expression that's a predicate and we'll
evaluate that expression on every row in
the input table and those rows for which
the expression is true we'll keep and
those for which is false will will will
drop this is a fairly simple expression
it's basically looking at one column the
value of one column in the row and
asking does it start with the the word
heap stir if it does that'll be true
otherwise it'll be false we'll see more
complex expressions in a little bit so
basically we're looking at the Container
column in all of the rows in the table
we're evaluating the
predicates on them we see the rows that
have the predicate returning true we
throw away all the rows where it returns
false and this is the output of the
filter operation so this is a way to
look at some specific subset of the data
that you want that you have in your
table the other thing you another thing
you might want to do is to get a
statistic about statistics about all of
the things in the table and that's done
by the group by operation so here we're
piping the output of the fetch into a
group I which has two arguments the
first is a map expression which is going
to tell us how to construct the time
series identify our columns in the
output table and here they're
constructed by just taking the cluster
name field from the input to a table
stream ID and that will be the stream ID
of the output and then the other part is
the aggregation acknowledge eyes and
push on the wrong buttons here the
aggregation expression which tells how
to combine the value columns of rows
that are mapped to the same place by
this so let's look at that in a little
more detail here we're showing one
stream out of the table we have all of
the stream ID identifiers column values
here and each row is represented by a
point in the table with its timestamp
and basically what we do what the the
map does is basically transform this
into this and this is now the time
series of the identify or the history
remains unchanged now if we do that
we're going to have a lot of time series
in the table with the same time series
identifier but we only want one time
series in the output with that
identifier so basically what we're going
to do is to apply the aggregator to
these we take all of the points at some
particular time and we apply the mean
aggregator to them getting the average
value and that goes into a point in the
output table with the same timestamp and
the mean value and we keep doing that
at each timestamp until we get to the
end of the table at which point now we
have one output time series for the
output table we do this for every value
of cluster name so for every value of
cluster name there'll be another group
of time series like this and we do the
same thing and that's how we produce the
output table all right so let's look at
that a little bit in action
okay we start with the basic fetch we
can and we can see there's quite a few
time series up on the screen here the
and every line on this screen represents
one time series in the table that was
fetched by that fetch now we can add a
filter to this and what are we gonna do
here we're gonna look at the namespace
name we're gonna look at the default
namespace and that's going to cut down
the rows that we have the street time
series that we have to a certain smaller
number of them and we are also going to
look we can act and further predicates
to that so we're going to only look some
of these are running on prim we're only
going to look at the on-prem ones all
right and once we've done that now we
can look at a group by and this group by
is throwing away all of the time series
identifiers so there's only one stream
in the output and it has the default
aggregator which is to sum but we can
replace that aggregator with an explicit
one we could say mean or we could say
standard deviation there's a very large
number of aggregators we could use but
besides giving a single aggregation
function we can make an expression we
could for instance divide the standard
deviation by the mean
to get the coefficient of variation and
that's what we have so this is over all
of the containers in our application now
the next thing we can do is go to the
map expression and here we're going to
put in this regular expression
extraction that extracts the first
component in the name of the in the pod
name of our container everything up to
the first - and so this gives us
aggregated information about each kind
of container that we are running all
right now after I've gone to all this
trouble to make a query I might want to
save it well you can do that there we go
you can save it you give it a name and
you can save it to a dashboard you could
create a new one or we're gonna use an
existing one and we save it I think we
save it does it not want to save itself
all right we're gonna try that again
it's the last day John there are
frightening on us all right you're gonna
have to trust us you really can't do
this and we would have gone to look at
the chart on the dashboard and shown
that you could edit the chart again in
fact we could go to the dashboard and
just edit some other chart just to show
this useful thing so this is also a way
of obviously of creating dashboards all
right here's one we saw saved earlier
today just to prove that we can do it
and you go back and you get a very
similar editor view of that alright so
let's go back now to the presentation
and so this is just for the record the
group I that we built before with a
little bit more here we've got an extra
field that we added to the mapping but
this is pretty much the same thing now
let's see look at some more advanced
queries from this this is the base kind
of queries that we've got so here we go
we're now up to 0.5 in our seven points
and one of the things that you might
want to do is to look at outliers that's
always a lot of fun particularly if your
aggregation says well there's something
wrong maybe you want to see if there's
something wrong with specific things so
for that you can use the top operation
it has two arguments the first says how
many things do you want to see out of
the collection of all the things and the
second says here's how to select them so
this is an aggregation function max is
an aggregation function that's applied
to all of the points in a time series to
get the maximum value of that time
series and then we look for the time
series which the top five time series
for that value you can use any kind of
aggregator here mean is also a good one
to use and you can also use bottom here
to look for things with the smallest
amount another thing that you often will
want to do is to look at more than one
query at a time so far we've just been
looking at one query here we in order to
do that you use these squiggly brackets
and join between the squiggly brackets
you have multiple queries here the
queries are very simple just a fetch
operation but they could be general
queries quite put put together by pipes
separated by semicolons
so this basically produces two different
tables one for each of the queries those
two tables then are piped into the join
which combines them into one table but
that table now has two value columns one
from each of the input tables and that
can be piped into a div operation which
takes the two values it takes the
divides them and produces a single ratio
and a single value column table for
output so let's look at that in a little
more detail so here's how tables are
piped through the join operation each of
the two queries produces a table those
two tables are independently input into
the join which combines the two tables
into one table with two value columns
the div takes that table with two value
columns divides the values in the value
column to produce a table with one value
column so how does the joint do that
transformation from two tables to one
basically it's two steps the first step
you're looking at every pair of rows one
from each of the two tables and asking
do they match up in the time series
identify ER fields and the time stamp
field and when they find to a pair that
does we say we have a match and we're
going to combine those two input rows
into a row in the output table and
that's done basically by taking the time
sir time series identify our columns and
the timestamp column which are the same
in both of those tables and those that's
those become the column values for that
row in the output and then taking the
value column from one table and the
value column from the other and those
become two value columns in the table
and this is basically your
straightforward relational database
natural join okay now here we just did
something very simple with that table
with two values in it we just divided
the two values but maybe you want to do
something a little more complex here
we're fetching of the reseed bytes and
sent bytes for a for a pod and we've
joined that so now every row in the
table has the number of received bytes
in the sent bytes and we want the number
of received bytes as a percent of the
total so that's this fairly
straightforward expression Vale's ero is
the first value in the table which is
the received by its value of 1 is the
second value we could have used received
byte count and set by count here they
wouldn't have fit on the slide as well
but
would be maybe more readable in some
sense we could have done that so that's
the sum of bytes sent and received
here's the bytes received times 100 and
dividing we get the percent of those so
the value table operation basically
allows us to create do arbitrary
computations on the input table the join
can handle multiple queries in it and
we'll join them all together so you can
look at more than two metrics at the
same time and you can create more than
one value column on the output
unfortunately at this time the metrics
Explorer will only display the first
value in the column but you might have
additional computations that could use
multiple values in the row and the value
operation will be quite happy to do that
for you all right
more demoing all right before we get we
actually had some latency it did which
is maybe we see here oh okay are we
gonna save the chart like why not save
the world actually they'd see a it's a
litany and this come we come back to
compare the chart oh no no JD
we keep doing this they're not gonna
believe that we can add alright where
are we now
no we did alerting did we do alerting no
we haven't done all right so one of the
things you might don't want to do with
the query is to set up an alert with it
so JD is going to go to the standard
alert creation policy creation and we're
going to add the condition and here we
see an editing window he's going to give
the condition a name there is we see a
no editing window very similar to the
one we saw before and with the little
editor thing there and now we're back in
the query notation editor
JD's going to add a query that basically
gives the
I mean utilization of all of the
containers by location and we want to
alert if that gets too high so he's
going to put an alert operation there
the alert operation has two arguments
the first is a boolean expression in
this case just checking a threshold but
it could be arbitrary and that when it's
true says the condition is is exists and
the second argument is a duration that
says how long the condition has to exist
before we fire and alert and having set
that up we can now save it I hope there
it goes and so there we see it in the
alert condition and the rest of it is
the standard thing for just setting up
alerts saying where you want it sent
some documentation so we're going to go
back now to the metrics Explorer we saw
a join that joined two different metrics
now we're going to look at a join that
takes one table produced by the fetch in
the filter in this example that's one
table and with the squiggly of brackets
is going to apply to continuation
queries to that one that's grouping by
the kind of POD the container is in and
the other is grouping everything
together and giving the total we join
those two and we divide and that gives
you the fraction of core usage time for
each kind of pod and one nice thing you
can do with that is to display it with
the stacked area graph and that shows
you a very nice breakdown of where the
CPU time is going in all of these in all
of your containers another thing that is
something that you would like to do is
to compare things between now and
sometime in the past
so here we have a query again we're
modifying a table that was produced by a
fetch and a filter and also a group by
is all part of producing a table this
one gives us basically the sum of core
usage time for each container name and
we do two things to it first we just on
one we just add a time series identifier
label that says when is now and on the
second one we add a label that says when
last week and then we time shift that
the the table and the time shift
basically takes one argument that says
how far are we shifting so we're
shifting values in the table from a week
ago to the present we're shifting them
forward in time so now we have a table
for now and a table for last week that
are both at the same time and you can
see the tables here as JD switches
between now and last week you can see a
comparison between what was going on
last week and next week
now here we used the Union operation
rather than the join to combine the
multiple tables because we wanted to see
both of these independently another way
to do this is we could do a time shift
and here we are again time shift one
we're just changing the vet in the name
of the value in the table and the other
we're shifting by a week and here we do
a join and then do a division and now we
see the ratio between what was going on
this week and what was going on last
week and some of this looks highly
erratic but that's because this app is
driven is being driven by robots and we
keep turning them on and off so it kind
of looks like that alright so time shift
another very nice thing that a stack
driver has is metadata which describes
various aspects of the resources and
here we have the metadata node named for
a container and
that basically says what node what
kubernetes node is that container
running on and so here we're using that
as a filter we have the name of a node
and we want to get all of the containers
whose metadata says I run on that node
together and that's what this filter is
doing and so now we can see for a
particular node what are all the
containers that are running on it so
metadata is a very nice thing it's
useful in filters now it'll be useful
before we get into beta and a lot of
other kinds of expressions to group by
them or use them in value expressions
all right and one last thing is let's
see oh no I got a couple of last thing
yeah okay so the next thing is here is a
query that basically is got a lot of a
lot of time series in it and one thing
we might want to do is to sort of cut
that down by doing a random selection
and we can do that by using the top
table operation with the hash time
series identifier operation so this is
now going to pick ten streams at random
by creating a random hash of the time
series for each times time series
identifier for each time series and then
just picking the top 10 and that which
will give us a random selection you can
see as JD moves the cursor and causes
the thing to recompute that the
selection changes we could put a seed in
here if we wanted to and then the
selection would be stable and would go
on every time we reevaluate it we'd get
the same thing depending on what you
want to do all right another thing we
can do with this or that we have in the
query notation is macros and those can
be used to kind of structure the way you
build a query so here we've got a macro
called container metric name which takes
one parameter metric which takes one
parameter and fetches a contain a
contain
and a metric name that's constructed
from the name but starts with the GU
Rene's container thing another that just
another macro that does a table
operation that just does a filtering
that we've seen before and a third and
expression macro that basically does the
regular regular expression extraction
we'd also seen before and now I can
express the that query and we've seen
this query before but I can express it
in a much more compact way and I think
at that point we're ready to go back to
the presentation and all right I'd say
but wait there's more the problem is I
think for most of that we've covered
most of this stuff now in the demos time
shifting alerting metadata and filter
operations one thing we haven't done is
talked about alignment and time you
would have noticed in the group by
example where I show the aggregation
computation marching through the time
series that all the time series
timestamps lined up very nicely this
typically doesn't happen automatically
or I mean doesn't happen isn't naturally
the case when we're collecting metrics
they tend to be spread out over time and
so what has to happen is a kind of
alignment operation that that takes the
time series in a table and lines up the
time things that need that like like
group by and join need that alignment
will do it automatically but you can
also do it explicitly using an align
operation raid allows you to change from
deltas to streams to rates from things
that are absolute changes that to
changes in time and every allows you to
control the period of evaluation of the
queries all of the queries we've seen up
until now have used about a 1 a sort of
a default 1-minute evaluation period and
actually
there is something I want to show you if
we could go back to the demo one more
time let's go back to sorry JD I can
what do you want to show put micros no
well that's fine now you see here that
this shows a one minute interval which
is the interval of what's showing on the
graph but if we go to a week for example
we see that the interval well you have
to get there we see the interval in the
graph is an hour so each vertical slice
of the graph is an hour now we're still
executing the query once every once
every minute and what you see here in
fact if JD would if you'll just mouse
over the the something in the in the
there we go
you'll see is that there's a central
line which is the average value that we
computed over that hour and then the
range of values a one-minute value so we
saw in the hour so you can as time gets
longer in the graph less resolute we
don't lose the spiciness of the
underlying data and we could if we
wanted to go over to the graph here and
add a vertical bar every one hour I'm
completely off the script now he's
probably gonna kill me what do you wanna
do a line oh I'm sorry every I apologize
yeah there you go and then one age yeah
there you go now here we're now
calculating the query at one-hour
intervals which completely matches the
graph and the the shading behind it
showing the spike eNOS has gone away all
right back to the presentation and we
covered everything else that's on this
list so I think JD its back to you to do
a recap here you very much John
so we showed you a lot of things there's
a lot of information to pack in and it's
a language and it's hard to digest now
the good news is you guys can access
this now and play with it and so if
you're a power user this is precisely
the sort of tool that you want to use to
get increased observer ability of your
applications your infrastructure your
cloud services whether it's Google cloud
or even coming from other cloud
providers cloud native infrastructure so
every single metric that exists in
stackdriver
and the time series as John mentioned if
there are in our time series database
then we can do all of these things and
so we introduced the stackdriver query
notation as a very flexible language to
as Joan showed incrementally build and
debug if if you want to very powerful
metric queries now you can use it as as
we saw partly with their saving the
dashboards but if you use it to analyze
time series on-demand and also to save
charge they are in their save charts and
to create alerts and so on everything
you know programmatically using this
query saving it there's a ton of other
features that the team is planning to
bring about so like I said if you're a
power user and this is something that
immediately resonates with you then you
can use it directly but also have a
documentation with sort of like a
cookbook and examples of things where
you can start this basic queries and
then extend forward now stackdriver is
just available in alpha and so you can
request access we have everything here
if this works if not use the URL that
you see there it's it's a it's a closed
program that we're running but please do
request access if you don't get
immediately access to it rest assured as
we expand the program will grant you
access we'd really want to bring this to
all of you and to certainly for the team
to get feedback and and tell us how we
can make it better and most useful to
your needs
[Music]